ブッダが超越の道っていうものを発見するんですね
ああいう風に世界を見ると
命を見ると かなりレベルが違うんですね
より具体的に 観察的に客観的に
自分の好み 期待などの主観をすべて
物事をありのままに観察する
それが仏教の世界 それで命の定義っていうことをするんです
命とは何で何だ で これからまああの
ちょっと次に始めた方がいいと思います
ちょっと休憩いたします
はい では始まります まあこれからそんなに話は難しくならないと思いますけど
まあまあ 仏教の話だけで
次に命って何っていうことを勉強します
体というものは一つの物体として見る
体っていうのは一つの物体なんですね
仏教では地水火風というんですね
物質は 4つだと仏教で言うんですよ
まあそれはまあ知ってる人は知ってるし
まあ知らない人は当然知らないしね
で 知りたければ本一冊できてますので
物質だけのことを書いてますからね
勉強してみれば物質は何かとわかると思います
椅子 壁 壁などの他の物体と比較してみます
だから この肉体 この物体とこの机という物体は物体だから
地水火風 こちらも地水火風
こちらも地水火風 どういったことはないんだというふうに発見するんです
比較するんですよ いわゆる私とこの机は何が違うんだろうと
これ大事なことなんです
命の発見するために 生き物としての物体と生き物でない物体の違いを探し出す
そこでこの物体 この地水火風は生き物としての地水火風
この机は地水火風なんですけど
生き物ではありません
それで生き物の地水 生き物の地水火風と生き物でないものの地水火風
地水火風 この間で何が違うのかと探すんですよ
すごい簡単単純なことなんです
それほど難しいことじゃないんです
2つのことを発見するんですよ
その時は  1生き物には物体にない物質もある
例えばこの体 生き物でしょ
この机は生き物ではありません
この机ないものはこの体であるんですね
物質は この感受性 例えば目っていうのは地水火風ですよ
これは本当に仏教の用語で理解しないと
ヨーロッパの科学で理解しちゃうとわからなくなっちゃうんです
ヨーロッパの科学はゴミみたいなもので扱うんだから
仏教はね だから今更それを論じても意味がないんです
だから地水火風論でいくんです
物質は 地水火風だったら
机も椅子も地水火風 この肉体も地水火風
しかし 例えば目をとってみましょう
目は地水火風でできてますけど
おかしいことに感受性があるんですね
光に反応する 机は光が当てて光を反射はするんだけど
特別な反応はないんです
それで感受性という物質があるんですね
それから性別 これはあの
なんていうの？オスの椅子とメスの椅子を見たことがありますかね？椅子にはオスメスはないでしょうに
机にもオスメスがないでしょうに
でも人間だったら この差があるんですね
それも物質ですよ それから艶でしたっけ
この艶っていうものはね
生きている物体には何か特別な艶があったりして
例えば他のものは磨けば艶があるんだけど
それだけ 特別に艶っていうものはないんです
生きている物体の場合は
何か特別な艶があるんですね
そんなものはね いくつありますか？テキストで書いてますのでね
2番目は認識機能 机と私の違うところは
私がものを認識する ものがあると知っている
この机はものがあると知らないんですね
それが大きな違い それは心というんですね
それで定義に入ります
認識機能がある物体は生命になる
そこで物体に認識機能があれば生命というんです
このマイクロスタンドは物体ですが
何も認識しない だから生命ではありません
ゴキブリも物体ですけど
ゴキブリは周りのことは知っている
だから生命です 周りの耳も目の耳も鼻もないミミズは
それなのに周りのことを知っている
ということは命です それで定義は何でしたっけ？認識機能がある物体は生命ということですね
これは一時的な定義で
物体が生命になるのは認識機能があるからなので
精密に言えば認識機能が生命です
さらに定義を定義を小さくするんです
物体に生命やというのは認識機能があるんだから
死体には生命と言わないでしょうに
犬が死んじゃったらただの死体ですね
死んだことで何になったかというと
可愛くて飼っていたペットの犬が死んだりする
死んじゃったらただ物体になったんですね
認識機能がなくなったんですね
名前を呼んでも聞こえないし
反応してくれない だから認識機能があるならば生命ということになるんです
認識機能が心という用語ですね
だからそれを仏教で心というんですね
認識機能 だから犬にも猫にもミミズにも心があるんです
認識するんだから そういうわけで
どんな生命にも心があるんです
物質と不可分離状態で機能すると
生命 パーリ語でサッターというんですね
なのです だいたい我々は物質と不可分離なんですね
認識することと体っていうのは離れませんね
見たければどうしても目が必要なんですよ
聞きたければどうしても耳が必要なんですね
だから我々は音を聞くという認識はすべて耳に頼っている
美味しいものを認識するといえば
どうしても舌にベロに頼っている
だから感覚と肉体っていうのは離れることはできませんね
不可分離状態 それで生命
に生命というんです 肉体があって心がある
物体があって心があるという 2つのセットは生命なんです
これはなかなか離すことはできないんです
まあわかりやすい例で私が言うのは
この水を持ってくると
ガラスに水を入れて持ってきますね
これ 離すことはできないんですよ
ガラスはいりません だから水だけ持ってきてくださいと私が頼んでも
これができませんね 水っていうのはいつでも入れ物は必要とするんです
しかし ガラスと水っていうのは不可分ででもないんでしょうね
だからガラスから水を飲めるんですよ
飲んだら体という入れ物に水が変わるんです
しかし 水だけガラスから離れて
あの宇宙船でいるような感じで
宇宙船で行ったら水だけ浮いてるでしょ
球になって たまたまテレビで見たことあると思いますけどね
それっていうのは地球上ではあり得ないんです
水には何か入れ物が必要ですね
で 入れ物は別なものに変わることができます
それで そのように我々の認識機能が肉体からどうしても離れないんですね
しかし だから絶対的にというわけじゃないんです
水と同じ 変えることはできます
それで生命っていうのは
このセットに物体と心
1セットで不可分にで機能するし
それに生命と呼ぶんです
物質に依存しない いわゆる体が持たない生命もあり得る
だから宇宙船に乗ったら
水が自分で一人でいられるでしょ
その場合はバラバラの形じゃないでしょうに
地球にある水っていうのは
入れ物の形をとるんですよ
ペットボトルに入れたらペットボトルの形
茶碗に入れたら茶碗の形
ガラスに入れたらガラスの形って形がもう変わるんですね
でも宇宙船で水をちょこっと外へ出しちゃうと
全部同じ形なんです 細長いとかはないんです
丸い形でしょう 丸くなるんです
きれいな球になるんですよ
完璧な球体 地球上で完璧な球体を作ることはできません
宇宙に行ったら 100%の完璧な球体は作れます
簡単です 水一滴垂らしちゃえば
もうこれ完璧な球体です
その場合は入れ物には入ってないんです
それのように体も体からも心が離してみればできますことなんです
しかし その時は心とほぼ完璧な状態にならないとね
離すことはできないんです
それで隅々に余計なことを言いますけど
あの宇宙空間ででも 水には入れ物なしに存在することはできませんよ
あれでも一つの入れ物なんですよ
どちらからでも引っ張らないんだから
自分で原子が互いに引き寄せて形をとっているんです
それも一つの入れ物なんです
どうでもいいんだけど
それは あの 一応仏教は普遍的な
誰にでも反対できない絶対的な真理を語るんだから
こういう風に厳密にややこしく定義されはするんです
微妙で間違いは現れないように
だから生命っていうのは何のこともない物体に認識機能があること
ということは 認識機能が生命ということになるんです
だから体に依存しようか依存しないしなかろうか
生命は生命です なんでそんなことを言うのかというと
一般の世界では人が死んで仏様の世界に行ったら
それで成仏できちゃってありがたくて
これで永遠やと勘違いしてるんですね
あるいは永遠の天国があるんだそうと勘違いしてるんです
仏教はその世界はあってもなくても
そちらでも肉体的な体があってもなくても
生命は生命ですということを言いたいんです
だからもうすべて把握
全部入るようにと語っているんですね
それから肉体と心についてさらに勉強します
物質すら DNA かアミノ酸ですね
ここら辺私はあんまりわからない
科学の世界だからね として合成された時点から普通の物質と違う働きをし始めるんですね
我々の体にあるのも ただごく普通のアミノ酸ですよ
まあこれ アミノ酸から元素で話すとややこしいんですけど
本当に小さい化学の方がすごい締まってしっかりしますよ
だから科学的なところはあまりわからないんですけど
まあ例えば最初の DNA か最初のアミノ酸か何とかできたとしますね
宇宙はじめでは宇宙ではなくて
地球ではね 地球ではもう最初の DNA かアミノ酸か何でもいいんだけど
出来上がったところで
その瞬間からこれがおかしいんですよ
宇宙の法則に逆らっちゃうんですね
科学的法則 宇宙法則と違った働きをする
それは知る機能があるからなんですよ
だから地球上で最初の生命が誕生した時でも
おかしいことをやってたんですよ
いろんな形の生命が段階があったようななんですけど
最初はこの酸素呼吸しない生命がいて
それがなくなっちゃって
今は酸素を呼吸 酸素をする生命になっていて
あの火山 あの 何て言いますか
この海底火山 海底火山の周りはすごい
もう毒ガスもあります
ものすごい熱いなのに
周りは生命がいるんですよ
それ私たちとは違いますけど
あんな強烈な熱いところで酸素はまるっきりない
猛毒のガスだけ 猛毒と言って
我々にとって猛毒 その中でも海底火山の周りにも生命がいるんですよ
だから生命っていうのは
どんなところでいても
地球上でいても 海底火山のそばにいても
酸素を呼吸しない あのナイ trogen なんで窒素
えっ？ん 窒素 まあとにかくナイ trogen なんとか取ってる生命であっても
自然法則に逆らってるんです
生命は これ知ることなんですよ
自分のことを知るも 周りのことを知るは
知ってるんだからもう変えたいんですね
それからおかしいでしょ？自分のコピーを作りたくなることは
このマイクスタンドは全然自分のコピー作ろうと思わないんですよ
一つ作ってくれれば金が上がります
ね やってくれないんですよ
もう 1本欲しいければ
お金払って買わなくちゃいけないんですね
生命はそうじゃないんですね
自分のコピーを作ろうとするんですね
これは微生物もやってるんです
バクテリアもやってるんです
ウイルスもやってるんです
だから DNA ができたら
もうおかしい その時点から自然法則に逆らっている
その逆らっていることっていうのはそれぞれ違いますけど
それは別に気にする必要はないんですよ
例えば水の中にいる微生物はね
それなりにちょこちょこって生きてるだけで
我々はもっと違うことをして生きてるんですけど
それはそんなに問題ないんだけど
基本的なところは この知るということなんです
ある日突然 DNA が知ることになるんですね
これ ある日突然でもないんだけど
同時に知ることになるんですね
これが生命の これはキリスト教の単語になりますけど
生命の誕生ということになるんですけどね
まあ本当はその説明は正しくないんだけど
皆様には正しくなければ理解できないからね
そういうふうに理解していた方がわかりやすいと思います
ある日 物質が知ることになる
それから生命なんです
知ることになった時点
すべてむちゃくちゃになるんですね
自分のコピー作ろうかとかね
もうそこまで考えちゃう
自分の形はそのまま そのまま維持しようではないかとも考える
壊れないようにしようではないかとも考える
この考えると言ったって
大胆なことじゃないんです
単語だけ大胆ですけどね
とにかくその気持ちはある
それから 知ることに基づいて
物質に違った形で 物質は違った形で変化してゆく
それでこのマイクスタンドはどのように変化するかということは
これは誰でもわかります
錆びちゃうし どんどん壊れていくし
やがてもう土に戻るでしょうし
私たちはそうじゃなくて
違う形で変化していくんですね
肉体は物質が それは知ることであるんだからなんですね
簡単に言えば 心が物質
体を支配し 管理するんですね
物質より心の機能が優先になるんです
そこである物体に知る機能が入ると
その物体がいろんな余計なことをする
で 余計なことをするといったっても
生命としていろんな機能はする
生きていきたいとかね
もう食べたいとか そこで心が知る機能が物質より優先なんです
物質といえば宇宙の物質と同じ
もう何のこともない しかし
そちらに知る機能が入ると物質をいじるんです
だから心っていうのは優先になるんですね
肉体以外の外の物質まで心が管理して支配するんですよ
そこで この体の中の物質も心が支配するし
外の物質も支配しようとするんです
特に人間がものすごい変な世界を作ったでしょ
人間が作った世界も自然法則に逆らっていますよ
人間が何かを作ったら
これは全部自然の中にないものなんです
例えば花 1本花瓶に入れても
挿しても これは自然の中にないものなんです
落ちてる石一つ拾って上のどこかに置いておく
それだけでも自然の中にないことなんです
これは他の生命も同じなんですよ
土の中にいるミミズも自然を変えるんです
生命はいつでも自然を変えるんです
自然の流れの中で自然と調和して生きましょうとか
何もわからない人々はえらいことを言って謳ってますけどね
これってのはありえないんです
命があること自体が自然を変えることなんです
時々すごい山を登ったりする人々
でも何かこの石をもうもう自分が自分が 1本の石をどこかにもう置いておくとかね
もあったりする それで山の上にそんな石の塊ないはずなんですね
でも人間がもう登れば登るほど
もう一人一人は 1個ずつ
一人は 1個ずつ積み重ねちゃいますから
やがて石の山ができちゃうんですね
それも自然にはないものなんです
そういうことで 高層ビルを作ったら
それは自然にないもので
電車を作ったらそれまた自然にないもので
それで皆様今食べている野菜もご飯
米も自然になかったものなんです
すべて不自然なものなんです
トマトは酸っぱいだからね
食べた食べ食べられないんだと思って
酸っぱくない甘いトマトを作ったり開発したりする
米っていうのは普通はもう硬いんだけど
やっぱり硬いものは食べたくないんだと
思って柔らかい米に開発する
それも自然にはないもの
で 皆様が食べる料理っていうのは自然だと思ってますかね
ないんです そんなものは
自然ままに食べたければ
もうまあ 虎とかね ライオンとかね
そんな感じで食べた方がいいでしょう
猿とか そのまま取って食べる
人間はたとえ塩をかけたらその時点で不自然です
だから知る機能がかなり働くんだから
我々人間が派手に自然を壊すんです
料理 フランス料理もあって
中華料理もありますからね
こんなのはいかに派手に自然を壊したかったかということなんです
知識が開発すればするほど
自然にとってはすごい迷惑なんです
自然ではただ物質だけの世界なんですけど
肉体と心の相互依存 別なテーマ
我々の肉体と心がお互いに依存しています
このパーリ語で言えば
ナーマルーパ パッチャー ヴィンヤーナ
ヴィンヤーナ パッチャー ナーマルーパンというサーリプッタ尊者の
好みの単語なんです  名色により認識が生じ
認識により名色が生じるというね
これ相互依存のことを言ってるんです
これはまあ知ってる方々は理解してください
知らない方々にはあまり関係ない
続けます 肉体そのものの
状態と外から入る情報によって心が変わる
で わかりやすく理解する場合はこういう理解するんですね
で これが自分の体があるんですね
体の状況が変わるたびに心も変わるんですよ
例えば 私は今 昨日もずっともう風邪が引いて
熱が出て もうもう最悪の状態で肉体が
それで肉体の変化が起きたんだから
同時に心も変化するんですね
だから何も考えることもできなくなっちゃって
まあもうこれは作れませんと
昨日作っちゃえば休みがあったのに
良かったんだけど やっぱりもう頭が動かない
まあ例えばなんか悪い食べ物を食べちゃうと
考え方までそれによって変わっちゃいますよ
だから 微妙にでも心体が変わると心も変わります
これすっごく依存しています
座ってる時の気持ちと立ってる時の気持ちが違うんです
だから体の形を変えることで結構頭を動かすことできますよ
例えば勉強なんかしたりすると
すぐもう眠っちゃうでしょうに
だったらずっと長い時間の授業でも
例えば手だけ上げたままで聞いてみればどうですかね
結構聞いてられますよ
眠くなりません 手を挙げるということは
意識が働くということなんです
心が変わるってことだ
だから 授業はつまらなくても意識が働いてるんだから話はわかるんです
だから先に先生に断っておいて
もうよく理解したいんだから
私は手を上げっぱなしでいますけど
あまり気にしないでくださいと
あれ 質問してるんじゃないんだと
だから ちょこっと体の形変わるだけで心は変わります
それだけじゃなくて 何か見たら心が変わる
何か聞いたら心が変わる
何か味わったら心が変わる
それも物質なんです 見るものは物質
地水火風 聞く音は物質
地水火風 だから仏教の物質論でなきゃ理解しにくいだけで
音は物質だとあんまり学校で教えてくれませんしね
光は物質なのにあんまり物質として教えてくれませんね
味は物質ですから 外から物質体に触れると心が変わる
肉体そのものの変化だったらまた心が変わるんだから
お互いに依存していますよ
だから いい心を作りたければ
音を選んで聞く 好きな音楽を選んで聞く
良い気分になりたければ
美しいものはわざと映画見たり
テレビ見たりする それで気分が良くなる
あるいはわざと美味しいものを食べたりする
それでまた心が変わる
だから一般の人々っていうのはかなり物質に依存していますよ
幸福っていうのは物質から来るんだぞと思ってるんですね
だから いろんな宗教で作ってる天国の話も
何のことなく人間の世界の関連的なコピーなんです
理想的なコピーなんです
理想といっても どうしても人間考えるものは矛盾だらけだから
ちょこっと考えるとおかしい世界とわかるんですけどね
今度は永遠の天国っていうのは考えるとおかしいんですよ
もうものすごく そこで死なないしね
死なないんだったら食べなくてもいいでしょうに
でもそちらは美しい美味しい食べ物があるんだと
いらんですけど そんなのは
美しい音楽を流れているんだと
何のために？聞かなくたってもいいのに
それで仏教的に何が理解するのかというと
やっぱり心と体っていうのはすっごいガッシリと互いに依存してあって
心が物質を変るし 変えるし
物質が心を変えちゃうし
怒らない人でも何か見せて怒らせることできるでしょうに
何か聞かせて怒らせることできるでしょうに
人に耳元でね もう怒鳴りたい放題怒鳴っちゃえば怒るでしょうに
ということは 音が心を変えたっていうことなんです
心の状態によって肉体は変わる
外の物質も変える そこで
私の心の状態によって私の肉体が変わっていくんですよ
これって大事なポイント
悪い心でいると悪い体になるんです
綺麗な心でいると綺麗な体になるんです
元気な心でいれば元気な肉体になるんです
それだけではなくて 自分の心が外の世界も変えたりする
体興味がなくても無視できない
それで仏教には興味がないんだけど
無視することもできなくなるんですね
これ 心と一緒に機能するんだから
体と不可分離状態なので完全無視はできない
体全体に心の機能知ることが働いている
体中知る機能が働いています
脳細胞で知るわけじゃないんです
知るだけだったら体全体で知ってるんです
健康で長生きしたいのは心です
健康で長生きしたいと思っているのは心なんですよ
スマートで美しい体を期待するのも心なんです
決してこの机はスマートになりたいと思わないんです
長生きしたいとも思わないんです
この机に心を入れてあげればすごい迷惑なんです
それからもっとスマートになりたいと思っちゃうんです
ちょっと私は長すぎでもっと短くなりたいとかね
余計なことを思ったりするんですよ
この肉体になっても もっと 2 3 ち上げれば伸びればいいなと思うのは心があるんだから
なんで心抜けちゃうと
例えば死体は思わないでしょうに
60 キロであろうとも
40 キロであろうとも
死体には関係ないんだけど
生きている場合は自分の体重は 60 か 40 かっていうことは結構気になるんですね
それは心なんですね 心には承知と全能があれば簡単に叶う目的ですよ
例えば長生きしたい 死にたくはない
美しくはなりたい いろんな希望あるでしょうね
これ 心の希望でしょ なりたければなればいいでしょうに
心が思ったことは承知
いわゆる正しい それから心には全能力があるならば
思う通りになりますよ
もし自分の心には善の力があったら
背が伸びてほしいなと思ったら伸びるんです
しかし それがないんですよ
覚えておいてください
これっていうのは結論ポイントで
あの心には承知と善能がないということ
知るんだけど 承知はないんです
知は承知ではないということ
もう結構進んでますけど
話は 生命っていうのは物体に知る機能があること
物体は知る機能があるんだけど
知るというのは知ですからね
これが承知ではありません
人間の認識は試行錯誤で得る感性に至らないものです
我々の知識っていうのは試行錯誤で得たものなんですよ
完成にはなりません これってわかりやすいと思いますよ
50年前の知識と今の知識は違いますからね
いろんなものを試行錯誤で新しい知識を作るんです
決して完成になりません
今正しいと執着する知識は
間もないうちに正しくないということになって訂正するんです
心は何でも変えようとするが
物質より優先だけで洗脳ではありません
心っていうのは何でも変えようとはする
でもそんな能力ないんですよ
だから能力ある範囲で変える
承知でない地で 世間では体に良いものを
頭に良いものを考えているんですよ
それで我々は勝手に考えてるでしょ
体に良いものは何か 頭に良いものは何かと
しかし 知は承知じゃないんです
正しくないんです だから正しくない知識でした
判断も正しくないんです
間違った理解でする判断は間違うでしょ
それでいまだに我々の思考っていうのは発展途上でしょ
知識は さらにさらに新しい知識開発するでしょ
新しい研究で ということは
100年前の人々はもう全然もうくだらないのはっきり物事を知らなかったし
それで我々も笑っちゃいますね
100年前の人々は本当に何も知らなかったなとかね
我々も笑われますね 将来の人々に
結局は誰でも不完全な知恵で知識でいるんですよ
不完全 不完全な知識で何か判断し
判断しちゃうと これまた間違いですよ
見事に その見事に間違った判断で体にいいものは何や？とかね
体に悪いものは何やと思ってもね
当てになりません ですから
承知を目指さなくちゃいけないんですよ
知る機能があるんだけど
それは正しくない だから承知を目指す
知は承知であるならば解決だという論理は当然です
もし知る機能が正しく働いて正しく知っているのならば
もう人間にも生命には問題ありません
知る機能が正しくないんだから
これを正さなくちゃいけないんですね
知る機能 正しくないということはあまり理解できないかもしれませんだけど
例えばこのご飯は美味しい食べ物ですよっていうのは知識でしょ
あれ正しくないんです
ご飯は美味しい食べ物というのは人間だけであって
真理ではありません 別な生命はそう思ってないんです
例えば野菜もというのはもう植物ですからね
まあこれはもう適当に切ってドレッシングをかけてサラダとして食べると美味しいというのは人間のことであって
試しにドレッシングをかけてもう牛に餌をあげてみてください
もう食べないんですよ
美味しくないんです そのまま葉っぱだったら食べるんです
そういうことで まあ我々が知っているのは
我々の世間 世界の主観の世界でということになります
だから知っていうのは自然に正しくないんです
しかし 試行錯誤での道は遠すぎ
遠い将来達するだろうと仮定しても
今生きる我々は不完全な知に頼って間違った生き方をすることになる
例えば科学者がね 遠い将来で全ての真理を発見したとしてもね
これも試行錯誤で これありえないんだけど
それ遠い将来のことなんですよ
今生きている私たちはどうですかね
私たちは間違っている知識で生きていなくちゃいけないんですね
だからこれってやっぱり科学に頼るということは救いの道じゃないんです
だから 科学至上主義な考え方はもう人間には幸福をもたらしません
それは科学が完成したところの話で
完成するかしないか まだ物質のことしか研究してないでしょうに
物質の研究終わってから心の研究に行かなくちゃいけないでしょうに
まだリンゴが落ちたことにびっくりした状態でしょうに
それで落ちたリンゴを観察した人間が
自分が立っていることにびっくりしたということから
もうまた勉強しなくちゃいけないんですよ
そこまでまだ科学は進んでないんです
まだリンゴが落ちることにびっくりしてるだけです
それからいろいろ宇宙船作ったり
もういろんなもうことはやったりはしてますけど
まだ心の研究はしてないんです
だから科学が完全完成したところで
まあ正しい知が現れるかもしれませんが
我々にとっては役に立ちませんよ
逆に科学の道では完成する見込みもありません
だから仏教は別な方法を考えているんです
今 正知を作りましょうと
ブッダの因果説はたちまち正知に達する方法です
この因果説の不思議なからくりがあるんですよ
みんななんか笑ってみるんですね
その不思議なからくりには
あの 一人だけ日本人でそのからくりを発見した人がいて
あの方何でしたっけ？飛
石飛さんという女性がね
あのブッダの論理学とか何とか
本いくつか書いてありまして
あの そちらにはこの本人が論理学的に
あ これってすごい完成しているんだと
やっぱり先知だとブッダはということはね
まあ論理的にたった一人だけなんですよ
みんな笑っちゃうんですね
ブッダの考え方に 何が何を知って笑っているのかと
それはこの因果法則の場合は
これがあるある時はこれがあるというね
それ逆も言うんですよ
これがない時 これがないと
普通読むと そんな言わなくていいで
うるさいでしょうと 余計なことダブってるだけではないかと思っちゃいますけど
そうじゃないんです それで智慧を完成するんです
いわゆる最終結論に至るんです
この因果法則の順番説と逆順の説では
例えば体にものが触れると
十感覚が生まれると まあ当たり前で終わらないんです
では 体に完全にものが触れない場合は
感覚は生まれないと ということは
体にものが触れると感覚が生まれるということですと
それではっきりした真理に至るんです
科学では半分しか因果法則を使っていないんです
これがあるとこれがあると
だからすごい いつでも不完全で終わっちゃうんです
いつでも大変迷惑なんですよ
車があれば楽に移動できるそうでいて
まあむちゃくちゃ車作るんですよ
一人一人一人に車 1台あればありがたくはない
ありがたいんじゃないか
ありがたいんだけど 迷惑ですけど
それで逆に ああ どうしようかと
大変やと 燃料が消えたらどうしようかというと
燃料は消えてから考えるんですよ
今燃料消えてますけど
これが最初の車 1台作った時
考えるべきでしたでしょうに
だから科学者っていうのは本当にいい加減ですよ
もし正しい科学者ならば
車が燃料を燃やして二酸化炭素を出して動いているんだと
それで二酸化炭素結果になるんだから
それは何かに使わなくちゃいけないと
そういうふうに思わなくちゃいけないし
あるいは逆に では燃えるものがなくなったらどうするのかと
それも考えておけばよかったのに
1個しか因果法則で考えませんね
燃料を燃やせればエネルギーがあってものは動くと
それで終わり ではものを作ります
と でも因果法則は中に入っていますけど
燃料があればあればものは燃える
燃えてエネルギーが現れてものが動くと
では燃料が消えたらっていうことがあるでしょ
それは気にしなかった
燃料を燃やしたら結果が出るでしょうに
その結果どうするのか
それは別な原因を作りますけど
だからずっとつなげてる
因果法則のチェーンっていうんですね
鎖  1個だけしか取らないんだから
それで何を作っても矛盾で終わっちゃうんです
その問題を お釈迦様は因果法則を発見するときは
見事に発見して これがあるときはこれがある
これが生まれるときはこれが生まれる
これがないときはこれもない
これが生まれないときはこれも生まれないというふうに完全セット作って語っているんだから
そこで智慧は完成するんです
もう調べることはないと
それで終わりということ
それで仏教の世界では非常に難しい因果法則だからやめましょう
次のテーマに入ります